let me pull up this story right here
from The Daily Mail this is why I think
that the Joe Biden FBI raid is actually
a cover-up Daily Mail reports what else
are they hiding White House claims
transparency face even White House
claims of transparency face even more
scrutiny as it's revealed National
Archives was blocked from releasing
statement on classified documents found
at Biden's Think Tank the Revelation
came during question questioning of
archives general counsel Gary Stern by
top Republican James Comer it raises
questions over who stopped the release
from going public that is to say just
before the midterms when they raided
Biden's home and they they knew he had
these documents the National Archives
were barred by someone
it'd have to be either Biden or Merit
Garland they said do not make a
statement you are barred from doing so
that means when the midterms came
everybody
nobody had the opportunity to learn this
CBS News eventually reports it and
that's how we find out